justement puisque les députés LR ne
participent pas aux votes sur ces motion
de censure et bien Emmanuel Macron a
estimé cette semaine qu'il pouvait y
avoir une alliance entre la majorité et
les républicains c'est envisageable non
pas l'état actuel d'abord il y a
plusieurs raisons à ça je crois que
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron a d'abord
beaucoup de problèmes avec sa propre
majorité on voit qu'il est il a de plus
en plus de mal à tenir la guerre de
succession qui est en train de
s'organiser chez Renaissance c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes je crois que
le principal problème aujourd'hui il
vient de là on a vu dans la discussion
budgétaire à l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement se faire mettre en minorité
par ses propres parties alliés c'est
dire que la situation politique est
complexe qu'Emmanuel Macron s'occupe
déjà de gérer correctement sa majorité
nous savons ce que nous avons à faire
dès le départ nous avons dit que nous
n'étions pas dans une logique d'alliance
de toute façon c'est des choses qui
prennent du temps long je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas encore changé
de logiciel qu'il change de logiciel
qu'il montre qu'il est capable d'essayer
de construire du compromis et ensuite
nous pourrons discuter mais c'est
clairement pas le cas aujourd'hui petite
question sur cette notion
[Musique]